[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to lab Roots the life
of her mind and interview series series
devoted to learning how women think
about their research their field and
their future let's get started today we
are in conversation with Dr Keisha
supernant director of The Institute of
Prairie and Indigenous archeology at the
University of Alberta Dr Superman is
also co-director of situated knowledges
indigenous peoples and place signature
area and chair of the unmarked Graves
working group of the Canadian
archaeological Association
in addition Dr Sue Bernat is the
co-editor of archeologies of the heart
and blurring timescapes subverting
Erasure remembering ghosts on the margin
of History margins of History
uh in addition uh Dr supernans is the
author of numerous Journal articles book
chapters reports and conference talks
and presentations hello Dr supernan and
welcome thank you I'm happy to be here
um there is so much exciting work to
discuss it's hard to know where to start
for example you are a groundbreaking
archaeologist a supervisor and mentor to
graduate students and an original
contributor both to the body of
knowledge about indigenous communities
and Indigenous feminism and to the way
we think about archeology so perhaps we
can navigate to those by way of how you
became an archaeologist how did you get
started yes my origin story I became
first interested in archeology actively
when I was a teenager and my father
actually was very much interested in all
things esoteric you know lost cities and
ancient Mysteries and that kind of thing
and he had turned me on to some of that
literature and I got really fascinated
by the idea of spending my life
traveling around and learning about the
past and uncovering things that were no
longer known I was so enamored of it as
a teenager that I really wanted to
explore how it how to make it my future
and I had gone to my high school
guidance counselor and I was probably 14
or 15 at the time and I was like so I
want to be an archaeologist how do I go
about doing that
it wasn't something that I think the
guidance counselor heard every day it
was a pretty small school but good for
them they they found a little bit of
information for me that basically said
to become an archaeologist you need to
go to graduate school uh get at least a
masters but ideally a PhD
uh neither of my parents finished
University they both went for like a
year and then dropped out I had no
concept of what a PhD was but I decided
then and there that that was what I was
going to do
at the time I was really interested in
ancient civilizations which I think for
many of us is one of the pathways into
archeology but throughout my educational
career I kept for two things kept
happening one is I kept being drawn to
work with indigenous communities I was
on the in the Pacific Northwest I I went
to the University of British Columbia in
Vancouver for my undergraduate degree
and was very much in contact in
conversation with indigenous communities
even in my undergrad I was also on a
journey of reconnecting at the same time
so I knew we were indigenous but my dad
was raised in child welfare system and
foster care so we had no idea to whom we
actually belonged growing up so I was
doing that at the same time as
developing as an archaeologist and
eventually those two things really
converged for me and that's where a lot
of this sort of generative work has
emerged from
when did you realize
um that the way that you think about
archeology is at least somewhat or
entirely uh unique I'm I'm thinking not
only about the worlds that you straddle
as an academic as a native uh um
Community member
um and and as a woman
um but also the way that you approach
thinking about archeology and thinking
about uh your sort of spatial and
philosophical orientations
um how did that what got you what made
you realize this about yourself
I think there's a number of moments
which I can trace back to that help me
understand the kind of lineage or
origins of how I approach the discipline
as a whole both from a practice
standpoint and from a more theoretical
or philosophical standpoint one of the
most important moments for me was when I
first did my archaeological field
training which was part of a field
school I run in direct collaboration
with a first nation in British Columbia
and this was in 2000 so it was before
this was commonplace in many areas and I
had the opportunity to learn alongside
community members like we were literally
digging in the unit next to them and
they were sharing with me their
understanding of their relationship to
the past and so that really planted an
important seed to me and Drew me back to
doing more collaborative practice in my
PhD work but I was working with my own
ways of knowing and being it was sort of
broadly about indigenous archeology but
it was really coming home so I now am in
Edmonton Alberta which is my homeland
this is where my father was born this is
where my metis family is from this area
of the world and it had me coming here
and coming back into direct relation
with my living relatives that I think
really helped me articulate
what it meant to be a metis
archaeologist right and and to be able
to think about both that relational
approach as well as what archeology
could be
and I think the spatial components to it
I was always a lot of archaeologists are
interested in things right the
materiality of the past is a big draw
for me it was never about the objects
themselves it was much more so about the
relations between them which now of
course makes perfect sense to me as an
indigenous archaeologist that I was
interested in relations between things
and so ever whether it was from when I
first got to encounter stratigraphic
drawings in my field school which I
became completely obsessed with and
loved them and then getting into
geographic information systems and
mapping and suddenly that made sense to
my brain like that's I just sort of this
whole world opened up to me in terms of
this facial relations between people and
land and again for me this aligns really
closely with an indigenous approach
where you can't separate out the objects
from the people who who to whom they
belonged or from the land in which
they're held for all this time until we
re-encounter them as archaeologists so
all these sort of things really
coalesced for me when I was able to come
and be in relation with what it meant to
be an at woman and an archaeologist
again other but I see those little
threads all the way back to you know
little baby archaeologists Keisha as
well and they'll bridge is able to
really come together in a really amazing
way
um and and a a big part of that I think
or at least that as you like as you
nicely call it part of your origin story
but more
um I think recent and in uh your history
that is when you were
um uh
you had begun working as as an
archaeologist but you but you started
um you know curing the the your
ancestors speak to you I wanted uh to
ask you about that in blurring
timescapes
um you rethink the concepts of ghosts
and haunting to profound effect
particularly as it forces a reader such
as myself to reconsider how we Orient
our attention and how we structure our
beliefs so just very quickly going back
to your point about objects and
objectivity
someone like
me and not just because of I think the
my training in philosophy and the sort
of philosophy in which I was trained but
also because of
um the culture in which I was born and
raised
um objectivity is really important and
thingness is really important separate
and apart from any relation right so
anyway so so as you develop this notion
of Haunting like I said it really has
this profound effect
um it it seems obvious now that
um seeing from multiple points of view
and thinking about ghosts and haunting
right creates a much more complete
picture of what there is and how we know
it
um but given that it sort of takes the
haunting that you describe for someone
like me to think about that
um
how do you
um
how do you approach uh uh the the
concepts of ghosts and hunting when
you're thinking about let's say writing
for an audience of someone uh that
includes people like me and I'm thinking
also for example about the fact that
because my picture is incomplete uh uh I
and many people uh would be ignorant are
ignorant of the the steps that the US
government and the Canadian government
took to annihilate really indigenous
peoples so so how do how did you get to
goats and and hunting and and how does
that work for
um for you to help someone like me yeah
thank you for that really rich question
there's a few pieces I want to pull out
from it the first is the one about how
ghosts and haunting uh kind of counter
this idea of objectivity is separate
from relation one of the things I think
I was always dissatisfied with as an
archaeologist as I was learning was this
separation of the object from not only
the person but also this idea that we
studied only with our minds right that
there really is this sort of cerebral
way in which we understand measure
categorize quantify these belongings
from ancient peoples and for me the
exploration of ghosts and haunting
invites a much broader
sensorial experience of archeology that
it's not simply about the measurement
and the category and the materiality of
the object it is about those other ways
in which we encounter it so there's an
emotional component a lot of times to
the archaeological work that we do
there's for many people not just me a
spiritual component but we never
talk about that we talk about that
around you know around the bar at a
conference where we tell ghost stories
to each other but we never make it part
of our academic thinking
and for me haunting is a really
generative concept because if something
if you're being haunted by something
it's not forgotten
just that's how I see it right so if if
something is forgotten there is no
haunting because it wouldn't even be
present at the corners of your
perception but a haunting means
something is insisting that it must be
remembered so this sense of insistence
of recurring kind of encounters and this
is how I really relate this to Erasure
and annihilation of indigenous peoples
and communities
both Canada and the United States are
built on a premise that indigenous
people are gone right that was the
fundamental founding premise they
operate a little differently because of
the particular histories of those
Nations but the core concept is the same
which is this settler population this
colonial population comes in and either
erases or subsumes all indigenous people
under it and we no longer exist as
separate Sovereign peoples
and my use of Haunting talking about
sort of the my encounters with with
ghosts and and with metis history is
that the haunting means we were
attempted to be erased but we are still
here
and we are still demanding to be
remembered in a particular kind of way
and in many ways I I would really see
that haunting is a step toward the
recognition of us as not just ghosts but
as still very much present here
um but hunting can be a way down that I
think for people who may not
um understand that we are still here and
even though we may live a lifestyle that
is not that disparate from a lot of
other people who live here now
although there's a lot of issues around
that as well and not having the same
kind of access to things uh but that the
core of how we are in the world remains
intact right even with the history of
boarding and residential schools even
with the kind of annihilation policies
of the US government and of Canada even
with the history of disease and
dispossession we still have our way of
life and we still have our ways of
knowing and being and they are valid
they are valid ways of knowing and being
and to me that's what haunting can kind
of offer is a way into understanding
some of that history
you mentioned the residential boarding
schools
um you have uh been a part of and and
initiated work on um uncovering it's
it's I I flabbergasted when I think
about if I'm not mistaken the
Saskatchewan school not I mean having
closed as recently as 1997.
um but anyway so so so you've used some
um techniques uh related to to to uh uh
mapping um I don't know if they're GIS
technique well you'll you'll tell us
what they are but
um so so you've you have
um
uncovered
um among other things you know unmarked
Graves you've located uh the the site of
of
um uh Braves of children who were at
residential schools you're you're trying
to help people complete a picture uh of
their own families
um children who were ripped away from
their families how did that come about
and what exactly do you do with what
techniques are you using to help
identify these areas
it's really interesting to me that I've
come to this place in my career I had
never been particularly interested in
ancestors I it's another way for a lot
of people to come into archeology is
they're really interested in bones and
human remains and that kind of thing
that was never me at all
but what really happened is when you
work with Community when you're you know
standing alongside and working alongside
community members you build
relationships of trust
and what started happening is
communities would ask can you help find
unmarked Graves
so I would be working with them when
we'd be doing things or being
conversation and they just kind of kept
coming up in conversation
my background was in sort of digital
archeology specifically around mapping
but a lot of the techniques that we use
to locate potential on Mark graves are
quite related they're very spatial in
their orientation so it was a pretty
easy way for me to kind of start to
incorporate some of those methods into
into my practice in general partly
because they're non-invasive so the
methods we use are there's a variety of
them but there's basically two main
categories there's forms of what we call
remote sensing which is understanding
something about the Earth from afar or
there's what's called near-surface
geophysics which is uh techniques that
use physical properties of the earth to
explore below the ground and the ones
that we are that we particularly use
when we're doing on our grades work are
ones that are focused on the top you
know 10 to 12 feet of the Earth because
there's ones that'll go much much deeper
as well
so I had been working with communities
on a variety of projects and then this
question of
you know can you help detect more Graves
kept coming up I also then had the
wonderful Fortune of connecting with a
very talented graduate student who had
come kind of trained with some of that
knowledge and we had access to the
equipment and we really started building
our capacity and this was before you
know in 2021 when the news from becomes
dishwash Mech about the cow move
spariels started to emerge we had
already been doing this work for a few
years both around residential school
sites but there are other places where
indigenous ancestors are buried where we
don't know where they are there's lots
of those too so not just residential
schools but Mass Graves associated with
the Spanish flu or with smallpox or
traditional burial places where we've
been dispossessed and removed from our
connection with those places for example
I am a descendant of a group in Edmonton
known as the Papas Chase creation we
were supposed to have a reserve land in
the southern part of the city we were
dispossessed of that in the 1880s but
one of our burial grounds is now in the
middle of the city but I don't know
exactly where so we were working with
you know I was working with my relatives
to try to find where that might be
because we knew generally but we didn't
know specifically and so using
techniques such as ground penetrating
radar which is a near surface geophysics
technique to map what's going on really
helps to you know bring more information
about where these places might be
located
training radar in particular has had a
lot of attention over the past year
because it was a technique used for the
Kamloops Indian residential school work
what it really does is it sends an
electromagnetic wave into the ground
like radar or sonar but you're just
pointing it down in the ground and as
the wave moves down it hits what's
underneath and bounces back to the
antenna when you know say you have soil
and there's a layer of soil and a layer
of soil it'll look different on the
machine and when that soil is Disturbed
it will look different as well so really
what we're looking for when we're using
ground penetrating radar is differences
in the soil and then we map them kind of
in three dimensions and when you find a
disturbance in the soil that is the
right size shape and depth that we might
expect of a grave then we say this could
be a grape uh doesn't detect remains or
anything but it can help us understand
locations that need to be investigated
further
um so does this uh so so when when
you've you've made um a possible
identification so so you've identified
an area for further exploration am I
right to think that that's further
exploration both by archaeologists but
also by in an interdisciplinary effort
maybe looking at you know historical
documents and interviewing uh uh
community members things like that
that's it is very interdisciplinary uh
and so this they can happen in sort of a
number of different different order
right so we often go to historical
documents uh and the history of land use
and Survivor knowledge first to help us
know where to start to look and then
once we've narrowed that down and we
found some results that weren't that
further investigation there's a few
things that can happen one you can go
back into some of those documentary
evidence you could work with the
community there's also potential for
forensic investigation that some
communities are exploring
um in order to get more information
about who might be in that grave and if
it is in fact you know has remains in it
that is a whole different process and no
communities are really at that point yet
because it is a huge and very very
difficult undertaking on many many
levels from both a scientific
perspective but from an emotional
perspective even just what's happening
right now with the locating of these
potential Graves is bringing up a lot of
that trauma for survivors and
communities because we're still
suffering from it as communities the
legacy of that is by no means gone right
it's part of the reason there's so many
issues that our communities are facing
because we've been ripped away from our
not only our families but our way of
life and and our understanding of our
place in the world for Generations
you're reminding me of the two things
one is the uh the the the fact that
uh on the one hand the
the the scientific undertaking is pretty
darn recent I mean it's you are I mean I
don't mean this as a pun it's it's
pretty groundbreaking work right I know
you're on the surface so you're
detecting certain you're officially not
digging but you know it it is
groundbreaking work so it's new in that
sense and yet it's also the case that so
much of this is enough in the recent
memory whether it's living memory or
inherited memory that
it does take a a fairly sensitive uh
multi-disciplinary approach to to deal
with successfully and that's like
initially was thinking oh well I'll ask
well so what happens once something you
know an individual has been identified
but you're saying no no we're very far
away from that we're not at that point
yet in multiple senses of that word
exactly and even that question may never
be fully answered because of that
there's so many factors that go into the
science of it and this has been one of
the things I found challenging in this
work is having to tell survivors who
have questions and relatives who have
questions that there's some questions
that we can't answer with science and
there's some uh children who are likely
lost to us forever and I wish the
science in fact were were more
sophisticated than it is it's already
you know we have a lot of different
techniques but the survivors will share
stories about things happening that we
can't trace you know and and that can be
really really hard but also survivors
also have knowledge right and it's also
about not I'm careful not to
frame what we're doing is validating
indigenous knowledge I think survivors
and communities have known for decades
that this that these children are buried
in somewhere in the community or they're
gone they've disappeared this is just a
process of being able to translate this
for folks who aren't indigenous
sometimes but also to provide that
locational specificity like here is the
place we think this could be
to help the community then decide how to
how to move forward with that
[Music]
um there was a a a second idea that I
had while you were uh talking a a moment
ago but what you just said also reminds
me of of another question so maybe I'll
ask both and you can choose what makes
the most sense to you to answer so first
you know you're thinking you so twice
you you've talked about you know place
right location and um if I'm not
mistaken uh much of your uh original and
continuing research is on the
overwintering sites for for uh uh the
Mayte people and uh how so I'm curious
about how you do that work especially
given
um the fact that I would imagine you
know some places have been developed and
and you know uh um you know how you go
about you know locating those
um but but then the the other part was
um speaking I was wondering if you could
speak to what you envision so you did
mention something about uh what you what
you can say to families to survivors and
what you can't right but what would what
do you envision as like the best
possible outcome over let's say the next
uh I don't know decade 30 years I'm not
sure what a good time frame would be
what what would you like to see yeah I
might start with that one and then I can
move a little bit into the tickets in a
slightly different direction I get asked
this question for a bit and I guess for
me what the best outcome would be was
the survivors having and the communities
having the ability to determine what
that is that it's not kind of
predetermined by
you know I can't go into a community and
say this is what I think the outcome
should be for you but I think it's
really important for them to have the
power to Define that outcome right to
say for our community this is what we
need and for some it's Justice it's a
sense that someone needs to be held
accountable someone needs to face the
consequences of what they did to our
children so for some that very much is
what I hear for others it's that
commemoration and memorialization this
idea that if the those children can be
remembered no longer haunting right
coming back to that concept but that
they can be acknowledged and recognized
as part of the community and there can
be ceremony and there can be that
healing component so for some it really
is about we need to know and tell this
truth so that we can begin really that
journey of healing and then for others
it is really wanting to bring children
home like sending them to where because
residential schools took children
sometimes from you know a thousand miles
away from home right huge distances and
this idea that you need to send the
children home in order for that healing
to begin but again what pathway is right
for which Community is not something
that I should say and not something that
the government should say right that
needs to be given that power it needs to
be given to communities and I think
there's different paths for different
schools from different histories and
different communities and it is going to
take you know I would say at least a
decade for any of this to get resolved
but the only way that it's this work is
done is when the community says it's
done
thank you yeah so overwintering so
overwintering sites
um have been the focus of a lot of my
work on metis archeology and
I guess a few things for me that I love
about meteorcheology is one it's a
relatively undefined field in which
there was a bit of scholarship that
happened in like the 1980s but it hasn't
really been a big topic of exploration
by academics
and to the point that native communities
in Canada today are not often considered
as having an archaeological heritage
if there's sort of this Erasure of us in
that has like we're in the historical
record but people don't tend to connect
that to the like physical material
places of the past Beyond a few kind of
core places like Winnipeg Manitoba is
the Red River settlement that's like a
core component to metis Identity the
area island is also really important
kind of place in in the metis history
but we were lots of places right and
we've been very much removed and
disconnected from those places
so when I'm going and trying to
understand our archaeological history
one of the reasons I was drawn to these
overwintering sites is that they were
kind of an important moment in time for
them at on our sort of development as a
people in a nation
but also they are very distinctly metis
so what they are are places where these
large bison hunting brigades that metis
folks would form in the summer would go
for the winter so they'd go out from
some of these major settlements build
their own little settlements out on the
Prairie in the Parkland
uh in sheltered areas with access to
Wood but also access to Winter bison
hunting
and these places were vast majority of
people who lived there and created those
places were metis whereas at say a fur
trade post you've got metis folks but
you've also got European settlers and
you've got First Nations and so it's a
bit more complex from a material
perspective so I was initially drawn to
overwintering sites as a place to sort
of evaluate what metis sites kind of
looked like now many of them have been
impacted by development but there are
also places where there's a fair bit
that remains intact so choosing a few of
those where we could get kind of a
baseline understanding of what metis
materiality looked like was really the
goal of that and then from that you can
take that kind of patterning that
understanding of native materiality and
start to look elsewhere
so earlier this year I actually gave a
paper around
re-reading fur trade archeology which in
Canada sort of the bulk of historical
archeology especially in western Canada
is all on kind of fur trading posts from
the 17 1800s
but there's almost never any real
mention of metis people in those
accounts
ironically we built every fur trading
post
basically in Alberta and Saskatchewan
and like huge amounts of these places
really almost entirely across western
Canada they were created by us and by
our ancestors who became us in many ways
and yet we're not present in the
literature at all in the archaeological
literature and I was just so I went back
to a bunch of these old reports and
started looking for the patterns that I
knew were associated with metis people
and then how the archaeologists writing
them kind of explain away some of those
patterns without really considering that
they might be you know that pile of
beads over there might not be a First
Nations woman that very well could be a
native woman but you don't talk about
that right or if it's not a metis woman
at the time certainly someone who then
likely gave birth to people who would
become metis right because we sort of
had these Collective interwoven
Community networks and family networks
that help to sort of form us as a people
people so for me there was this really
important piece around the materiality
can provide a different understanding
again not for our people so much but for
everyone else about where we were and
the kind of richness of our material
history and help to tell our story which
is ultimately what we want to be able to
do
and you've talked about
um being Guided by uh interest in
um identity as as one of your interests
and I was uh thinking about that with
respect to
um the the ways that we what we choose
to focus on that then becomes
another's identity so for example
um looking at at beads and and
identifying it as one thing to the
exclusion because you hadn't considered
some other possibility so
um when you talk about being interested
in identity are you thinking about
this very
um uh special
uh thinking about identity and sorry let
me back out of that when you're thinking
about identity are you thinking about
identity in terms of relationships or
identity in terms of like okay here's a
discrete object that's separate from uh
everything else that kind of goes back
to that objectivity uh issue I would say
that if you'd ask me that question 10
years ago my answer would have been
closer to the latter than the former
which was that I I think when I first
was encountering the kind of theoretical
body of work of identity which was
definitely an interest which of course
I ca I always think about how this
relates to me and the sense that I
didn't know my identity really and what
that meant and so I became really
fascinated with studying it because then
it was something I could try to
understand but very much I would say now
my understanding of identity is one that
is deeply relational and intersectional
so it's not so much that you know this
is a metis object because it is
inherently it's about the relations to
place to ways of knowing to family to
kinscape which is a term that I find
really evocative this idea of the
relationship between place and kin
relations and that can be kin both in
terms of humans but other than humans as
well and this idea of the sort of inter
interweb interest secting web of
relations so for me identity kind of
emerges from those relations and this is
really important when it comes to metis
people because for a long time in many
ways still
there's been this way of identifying us
as being of mixed European and First
Nations descent in Canada so that that
is really the fundamental quality of
what it means to be metis but there are
lots of people who are mixed who are not
metis there's lots of First Nations
folks who I might have a a you know a
white grandfather or even parent and
they're still you know Cree or Blackfoot
or you know anishinaabe
so it's not so much that there's a
fundamental mixedness that lies of our
heart but it's more so there was this
history of families
um so the or our origin story is ones of
yes there was indigenous women and
European men who had children but then
those children tended to marry children
from similar unions for Generations so
if you look at my family tree I have
like four or five generations of metis
people marrying other metis people and
really creating a sense of community and
identity that was about that relation
and about the relations to the places
where we were as well and this is for me
how I have come to really understand
identity and it's also why I struggle
when sometimes you have folks who are
you know have one indigenous ancestor
the Cherokee princess model in the U.S
but here it's very much like oh I have
an indigenous ancestor that makes me an
ET well no that doesn't what makes you
met is that history of relation and I
couldn't fully be metis until I was back
in relation with that and because it's
not just about I am you know related to
it's about the responsibility of that
relation it's about being a good
relation right being able to work for
the the community and and support
telling our story not just cleaning but
being claimed by that Community as well
and that also that reminds me of a
some some of what I've read but also
what you've mentioned this notion that
um there are lots of voices
to be heard and who can help to create
the full picture of what you know
whatever story you're you're trying to
learn or trying to understand
um so yeah that's an incredibly helpful
to to thinking about
um what it is that you're doing
um I know that your time is valuable
I've got one more question if I may
um and of course I want to know if
there's something that you would like uh
to share with with uh with viewers and
listeners uh first the the question um
there's a territorial acknowledgment on
the University of Alberta web pages
um and I'm wondering what this sort of
acknowledgment does for indigenous
communities
um as well as for those of us who have
spent so much of our lives in complete
or partial ignorance
of the reality of these voices and this
history and this identity
Divine acknowledgments especially in
North America
as a way of again bringing forth some of
that history of you know this these are
the traditional territories you know of
a particular Nation or set of Nations
Edmonton where I'm located is a
particularly interesting one because it
has many nations who have a connection
in history here and that it's always
been kind of a gathering and meeting
place a place of coming together so we
have a lot of Nations listed on our
territorial acknowledgment but other
places are very clearly connected to a
history of a particular indigenous
Nation
I've heard critiques certainly of land
acknowledgments in that they are just
words right this idea that you know do
they actually lead to any concrete
action and I think in many ways that is
a a valid critique and and can be quite
performative right that's where we do
this just because we we've been trained
to do it now or we've you know have it
in our signature line because that was
on our University website
at the same time I've spoken with a
number of Elders who really it's so
valuable to that that that's happening
because they grew up in a time where
they were completely erased from these
spaces certainly from universities it
wasn't something that was very present
you know 30 40 years ago and therefore
that acknowledgment really makes them
feel seen right and again sort of taking
from that realm of Haunting to actually
that corporeal realm of like this is not
the traditional territory and the one in
the University of Alberta also tries to
talk about you know the kind of Vibrant
Community that's still here so it's not
just about this is was the traditional
territory like this is the traditional
territory and there are these people
still still here and still contributing
to to the community so I think that it's
a step along a path of
um you know remembering and then trying
to account for the lands in which many
of these institutions sit which were
stolen from indigenous people and
sometimes very actively you play the
part in dispossession so I think it's
important uh as a step toward
understanding that but it is not in and
of itself enough right it brings more
into the conversation but it can't be
the ending place of this it has to be
the starting place of a journey to
really understand and think about what
does it actually mean to account for
that history
um as well
well I want to know if there is anything
that that you're working on or that
you're thinking about or that you would
like to to mention uh to to to our
viewers uh before we sign off but but
before that I want to thank you again
for your time
um it has been a real privilege and a
pleasure thank you thank you thank you
for making time to chat with us today I
was really happy to be here I think the
only thing that I would want to bring up
a bit that we didn't really touch on is
a lot of what I've talked about uh in in
this conversation today
is really well summed up by the
heart-centered archeology that I have
worked with some dear friends
um and colleagues on so the book
archeology of the heart which I
co-edited with Sony Adelaide Natasha
Lyons and Jane Baxter
was really our attempt to take some of
these principles some of which are
connected to indigenous archeology some
sort of feminist archeology but they're
fundamentally about inviting a different
way to be an archaeologist and to do
archaeological work so it's as much
about how we care for each other in the
present because archeology has had a
very
ugly history of
um violence toward all kinds of
different people and the nature of the
discipline has been one that's been very
exclusionary that's done a lot of harm
both in terms of what we've extracted
from the ground but also in terms of how
we've treated one another as
archaeologists so it's our invitation to
be more expansive to invite in Emotion
to invite in that sense of care but to
remain with a strong commitment to doing
excellent high quality work that it's
not um
having an emotional connection to
something doesn't actually reduce our
ability to use excellent scientific
methods in fact it improves my science
when I care and I I am not going to tell
an indigenous community that I found in
a market grade one I haven't that would
be so deeply unethical to me so I have
to really do the best science I can and
those things are actually deeply
interconnected and then that relational
piece and we need to be good relations
to the belongings of ancestors of the
past but we also need to be good
relations to one another so to work
against a sort of hierarchical models
and those power dynamics to recognize
and respect them to be more
collaborative in community oriented Even
in our how we run our lab how we work
with students and so for me this is a
very It's a Wonderful way to kind of
take some of the principles that I see
at the core of indigenous archeology but
also connect them in with other similar
movements right other similar ways that
people are thinking about archeology and
what it can and should be globally
right because it's this idea that we
want to create a space where any
archaeologist with a heart can practice
heart-centered archeology and that was
our invitation really in the book what
so so one more time heart is an acronym
for yeah uh heart-centered
I have to remember how we did it
um
RT I remember
heart centered and emotional
archeologies for research and teaching
h-e-a-r-t uh is the acronym and is this
Collective of women at this point it's
it's majority women who are really sort
of thinking through and feeling through
a lot of this and we've had an amazing
response to the book itself and to the
work of Heart Center practice because
especially a younger generation of
archaeologists from all sort of genders
and backgrounds I think have been
looking for an approach so even if their
interests are in in a very different
realm than say indigenous archeology
they want to do archeology differently
and they want to do archeology that
really matters that has a positive
contribution in the world today in a
very direct way so not just archeology
for the sake of knowing the history of
humanity but archeology for addressing
the history of colonization or for
telling different kinds of stories and I
see such an amazing generation of
archaeologists emerging who are going to
really lead us and all kinds of new and
amazing directions it gives me a lot of
Hope oh that's a wonderful note on which
to end and I will make sure that we have
um a link to uh is there there a heart
website or can folks get to that through
your faculty or yeah they can I mean I
would direct people to the book first
um as well and then and then we had
we've been talking about a website but
we don't have one yet so all right we'll
make sure we have a a link to the book
Thank you so much once again I
appreciate your time and your work um
you're very generous and uh thank you
thank you thank you yeah it was great
talking with you